>>Christina: For every one that's here in
the room today, and everyone that's in VC
offices around London, thank you very much
for coming to today's Authors@ series.
My name is Christina Smith, I'd like to introduce
you to three fine gentleman.
Well two fine gentleman, one guy I just met
a few minutes ago so we'll see how that goes.
[laughter]
From the illustrious Pub Quiz team that I've
been fortunate enough to know for the past
few years you've got Richard Moore, Daniel
Freebie.
They're gonna walk you through.
God I feel like I'm doing like a client presentation
right now.
We're gonna walk you through a few samples
today.
[laughter]
They're gonna talk to you today about their
best-selling books that have been out for
awhile.
"Slaying the Badger," and what is the Eddy
Merckx cannibal.
>>Daniel: Cannibal.
Something like that, OK.
And then also joining us today if two is not
enough, we're very very fortunate as well
to have Mr. Ned Boulting here.
Ned's book, "How I Won the Yellow Jumper",
has been out for probably three years now?
>>Ned: No no, 10 months.
>>Christina: 10 months, god it feels like
it's been out longer.
You write for the—
>>Ned: I get to use a microphone now.
>>Christina: And you write for "The Guardian"
is that right?
>>Ned: No I broadcast for ITV, it's television
but yeah.
>>Christina: Okay, close enough.
You can tell I really, I'm just completely
winging it.
Sorry, not "The Guardian".
>>Richard: You got him confused with someone
else.
[laughter]
>>Christina: Daily Mail?
>>Ned: You can just, you've googled me.
>>Christina: I did, actually I google everything.
I should have just read what I wrote a couple
moments ago.
Alright with that embarrassing last comment,
I'm gonna shut up and just let these guys
take it away.
All right, this is gonna be a really fun hour
so I'm excited about what's gonna happen.
Alright.
>>Richard: Thank you, thank you Christina
for that wonderful introduction.
These are the three books she mentioned.
We were gonna sort of basically talk maybe
10 to 15 min. about each one
>>Ned: 10 Minutes
>>Richard: With the author being quizzed on
his book.
And we thought we'd start with Ned's, "How
I Won the Yellow Jumper."
Which is a kind a great introduction to the
sport.
Because it covers your own introduction to
the sport.
You were a highly competent experienced professional
broadcaster who was parachuted into the.
[Loud Siren Noise]
Ned, is that you?
>>Ned: [slap] got it.
[laughter]
>>Richard: You were parachuted into the.
[loud sirens stopped]
[laughter]
Tour de France in 2003.
The title of the book comes from a pretty
embarrassing encounter you had on the Champs-Elysees
after the first stage of Prague time trial.
Can you tell us?
>>Ned: In very brief summary it was the first
bike race I'd ever seen of any description.
I'd never ridden a bike, raced a bike, seen
a bike race.
So my first introduction to it was the prologue
of the 2003 Tour de France which cycling fans
here will remember, turns out to be one of
the most epic in modern times.
The prologue was in Paris which is unusual
in itself, so the setting was extremely grand.
Not only that, to compound the importance
of the occasion.
But a British rider David Miller pre-doping
ban was actually the hot favorite.
>>: Daniel: Mid-doping.
>>Ned: Mid-doping was for good reason the
hot favorite to win that day.
[laughter]
And so he should've done actually had it not
been for the fact that in the final bend onto
the final home straight his chain bounced
off his chain ring and he lost time and just
missed out.
Anyway, this all sort of, we were broadcasting
live on ITV 1 actually then, not on ITV 4.
So on the big network to a big audience.
And all this chaos ensued where we thought
we had this British winner and in the end
he missed out by a fraction of the second,
rode over the line, disappeared and we had
to find out what had happened to him because
we couldn't get an interview with David Miller.
And it's one of those broadcasting situations
where television is in desperate need for
information to relay home but more often than
not you haven't got it.
So you start kind of making stuff up.
And the director without really warning me
just suddenly made the presenter Gary Imlach
run out of things to say.
Cause he had used up all the scanned information
he had.
He kind of threw across to me to say what
I knew about the situation.
And I was in a complete state of confusion,
so the only thing that came out of my mouth
was, "David Miller's just blown his chances
of winning the yellow jumper."
Not realizing that of course it's not a jumper,
it's a jersey, it's an iconic sporting trophy
and I just made a bloody fool of myself.
I didn't realize I'd done that until much
later when some people told me how much of
a tit I'd made out of myself.
So that was it.
So that's, in terms of that book that's the
starting point.
That's the ignorance in which I could only
improve my knowledge.
>>Richard: Yeah.
You'd worked in other sports, football most
notably before then.
You covered that whole tour.
What was it about the tour that fascinated
you and what surprised you about it as well
as you kind of got to know and love it?
>>Ned: Well I guess, firstly the scale of
the event.
Because, Daniel you been on the Tour de France,
you've done it many times and I'm sure amongst
our audience here.
And that bloke sitting over there on his own,
hello mate.
>>Daniel: Where is that guy?
>>Ned: I don't know where he is, it doesn't
matter don't ask.
Anyway I'm sure amongst us all, we've all
been and seen the Tour de France.
And it's only when you actually see it face
to face you realize quite the scale of the
operation.
So in terms of what I do, broadcasting for
a television network what's called the zone
technique which is the TV compound area that
you guys occasionally are allowed access to,
you print journalist.
But you know.
Just the size of that, the number of big TV
trucks and the amount of cabling and different
countries represented there is comparable
only I think.
I mean its way bigger than a World Cup Final
in football which would be way bigger.
>>Richard: Really?
>>Ned: It's much bigger than a Champions League
final, probably the doubles the amount of
trucks.
I think it's comparable to just gonna maybe
US presidential race in terms of the.
>>Richard: Wow, that surprises me.
>>Ned: It's just staggering.
So in terms of the television side, I just
went my God.
German television turns up year after year,
apparently they're not interested in it anymore
so they've kinda scaled back their presence.
They had 85 television vehicles on the race
every year.
I mean we don't we've got three.
[laughter]
So the scale was just breathtaking.
Lance Armstrong of course in 2003 that was
his fifth win.
So his stock was possibly never higher than
then.
And the interest in him was vast.
And everywhere he went he was just descended
upon by hundreds and hundreds of journalists.
I mean it was as if David Beckham had signed
for Real Madrid every day of the week three
times.
You know, it was kind of, that blew me away.
And then there's sort of a flipside of that.
And it's perhaps contradictory.
But the access I got to these riders having
worked in the very sanitized world of football
where you can't get near the buggers.
Just amazed me that you could go and knock
on their door, find out which hotel room they
were sleeping him because they'd tell you
at the reception.
What room?
Oh well there's a list.
>>Richard: Well there's some curious things.
>>Ned: Just nuts.
So all that thrilled me and excited me
And over the years, the penny dropped that
actually as a broadcast journalist and obviously
is a written journalist.
Not only are you granted huge access to this
great occasion but you can actually drive
the agenda and even determine the outcome
of the race.
When I think of the way we persecuted Michael
Rasmussen in 2007.
We ultimately were the motor that got him
booted off the race.
If we hadn't been doing our job in the way
that we did it, someone else would've won.
And so that doesn't happen in football.
You can't step on the pitch and get involved.
But in cycling, you kind of can.
>>Richard: The lines are far more blurred
aren't they?
>>Ned: The lines are blurred, it's fascinating.
>>Richard: And there is that paradoxical element
to the scale on one hand and the access on
the other.
And one of the things that comes out in your
book is your relationships with the riders
as they develop.
>>Ned: Or not, yeah.
>>Richard: Or not.
Or appear to develop and then.
I mean it's very much like your story of your
dealings with Mark Cavendish for example.
It's like a courtship.
You know where we.
>>Ned: It's quite one sided.
[laughter]
>>Richard: Unrequited love.
>>Ned: Yeah, yeah.
>>Richard: But you feel it-
>>Ned: I've got a huge crush on him.
>>Richard: On occasions yeah.
But it's fascinating how, and it's a very
interesting kind of study of how journalists
interact with those athletes.
I think you probably got some thoughts on
that as well Daniel cause you obviously.
For those of us who don't know, Daniel is
Mark Cavendish's ghost so to speak.
>>Ned: "Boy Racer", Mark Cavendish's book
was actually written by this fella.
>>Daniel: I collaborated.
I dotted a few "i's"
>>Ned: "Boy Racer", was written by.
>>Richard: He sorted out the grammar and the
spelling and stuff.
[laughter]
But yeah, you know Mark very well.
But what comes across in the book is your
crush on Cavendish.
[laughter]
And there is this kind of, and then it's followed
up in your follow-up book, a mini book which
is called "How Cam Won the Green Jersey."
Which was an e-book published last year.
You know, so it's a fascinating, like can
you tell us a little bit about how you and
Mark?
>>Ned: Well no let me just, very briefly I'd
like to you know come to you in a second.
But I, I have repeatedly,
Mark and I have this game where I ask him
for his mobile phone number and he says no.
>>Daniel: I've got it actually.
[laughter]
>>Ned: Well that's the interesting thing,
so I've, I mean every time I've seen him I've
gone, "Can I have your mobile phone number?"
And he goes "No."
And then I'll say, "Well I'll it again in
20 minutes, see what you say."
So I, "Can I have your mobile phone number",
he'll go, "No you can't."
This goes on and on.
>>Richard: But things seem to be going very
well for you at certain points.
>>Ned: Yeah, but that's a funny thing about
Mark, he does kind of.
>>Richard: Lead you on.
>>Ned: Blow hot and cold.
And you know, he never gives you anything
other than compelling television I think,
whether he's.
In fact he's at his most compelling when he's
got a right ass with you.
Because that's when you see the true.
You know it makes my job slightly uncomfortable.
But I'm not there to be his mate, I'm there
to kind of be the lightning conductor and
the filter through which we experience what
he is as a person.
What drives him.
And I think that across most when he's got
the ass with you, which is quite often.
>>Richard: how uncomfortable are those moments?
>>Ned: Oh, hideously.
It sucks the air out of the room.
I mean it's just, when Mark doesn't want.
You know I'm interested in your take on this.
When Mark doesn't want to cooperate or when
he thinks you are letting yourself down or
not paying him enough respect or failing to
understand him or just being daft which is
quite often.
He just has a way of shutting down the communication,
doesn't he?
It's quite unique.
I mean did you find that, even when you're
you know, when you're writing the book with
them?
>>Daniel: I think he's very fickle.
He tends to make up his mind about people.
And, he's obviously made up his mind about
you.
[laughter]
If he likes you he tends to be fine.
I mean I remember about a year or two ago
you know I'd done the whole book with him
and we got on pretty well.
I wouldn't call us friends, but we had a good
professional relationship.
And I had to do a magazine feature.
And I called him up and asked him to couple
questions.
And I asked him one question, I think it was
about a race.
Milan-San Remo last year or the year before.
And there was a pause on the end the phone.
It was a phone interview.
He said, "Daniel, I don't think I've said
this to you before, that was fucking stupid
question."
[laughter]
>>Daniel: And I mean that's kind a typical
of him, like you say even when he's pissed
off it can be very compelling.
>>Ned: Incidentally I've got his mobile phone
number now because another journalist gave
it to me and said by the way here.
But I've never used it.
I'm far too proud to use it now it, because
it hasn't come from him so I'm not gonna use
it.
But, I'll sell it to anyone in this room for
about a tenner.
[laughter]
>>Richard: Or anyone in the googlesphere.
>>Daniel: That's just us then.
>>Ned: The other guys disappeared.
>>Richard: But, you know that's one very interesting
aspect.
And these characters are kind of a big part
of the story that you tell in the book it.
Lance Armstrong being another one.
I mean you've obviously covered lots of major
sports, how does Lance Armstrong compare to
some of the kind of A-listers in football
for example?
>>Ned: Armstrong's in the same way that Cavendish
is a bundle of contradictions, so too is Armstrong.
But I mean Armstrong, I've lost interest in
him a bit now.
But that's only quite recently.
I mean I found him absolutely compelling in
all sorts of different ways.
Because he, you know I found tussling with
him on the finish line a different kind of
experience.
Cause he was quite even-tempered.
But he had this way of fixing you with a little
glare.
And lying through his teeth to you like that.
And you kind of knew it was a lie and he knew
that you knew it was a lie.
But we were playing this game and it sort
of dancing around that.
But it was such fun with him.
I did, for all we think of his record as an
athlete, good and bad, he was compelling I
think to watch in all situations.
>>Richard: Shall we kind of segue very smoothly
from talking about Armstrong to talking about
the rider to whom Armstrong was perhaps--
>>Ned: Lifetime champion, yeah.
>>Richard: compared the most.
"The Cannibal", Eddy Merckx, the greatest
cyclist of them all.
Who quite strangely enough for Merckx and
Armstrong were kind of rivals through history
in a sense.
Merckx is generally acknowledged as the greatest
cyclist of all time, and Armstrong though
during his reign was regularly kind of mentioned
as perhaps the greatest cyclist of all time.
Can you maybe just tell us a little bit about
your approach to this book?
Because Merckx didn't cooperate as such with
you did he?
>>Daniel: No he told me pretty much from the
outset that he wouldn't collaborate.
I don't think that's that unusual with biographies.
I think, and it kind of freed me up really.
I didn't, he's one of these people, he's really
dehumanized and demystified himself over the
last 30 or 40 years since he's been retired.
Kind of disappointingly, like Pele you know
with his Viagra adverts and you know the nonsense.
>>Ned: MasterCard.
>>Daniel: Yeah, MasterCard and the nonsense
he talks about the current Brazilian footballers.
So Merckx is quite a disappointing character.
But when you juxtapose that with his achievements
which are just extraordinary and the person
he turned into when he was on a bike, that
in itself was fascinating.
But it was really that that I wanted to concentrate
on.
Because, we're not that interested in, I mean,
it goes back to what you are saying about
your interactions with these guys.
We're not that interested in them as human
beings, we're interested in them because they
can do things that we can't.
And that was very much the case with Merckx.
And another thing that I really wanted to
tell was the story of all the people's lives,
careers he ruined.
I mean he sounds like a despot and he kind
of was on a bike.
And there was this whole generation of guys
who could and probably thought when they were
19, 20, 21 that they were gonna be you know
Mohammed Ali on a bike, or Pele on a bike.
And that didn't happen.
And it was interesting really looking at how
that shaped them as characters.
It actually made the more complete characters
than Merckx.
And Merckx sort of remained this kind of Peter
Pan never grew up, because you know losing
is an inexperience, we all have setbacks in
our lives.
But Merckx managed to keep a lid on everything.
And kind of remain in his own mind immortal,
invulnerable until the age of about 32, 33
when he finally lost for the first time.
And then couldn't deal with it, he found it
very, very difficult to deal with.
>>Ned: Can I just ask Daniel, I mean having
to learn about cycling history in the way
that I have to because I didn't watch it first
time around.
And anyway, Merckx was before my time.
But what I really got from your book was a
sense of a rider who could do it on all terrains.
And that's kind of remarkable in the modern
era to think back to a rider who did that.
So he could time trial like no other.
He could win rolling intermediate stages.
He won in the high mountains and he could
win up on sprint.
If you chucked Eddy Merckx on to a carbon
fiber bike and stuck him in a modern peloton,
where would you find his, what would he do?
What would he achieve?
And where would that take him?
>>Daniel: It's a good question.
I actually just wrote a magazine feature about
this.
I think the way cycling has gone, it's become
so specialized, kind of disappointingly so.
To the extent where a guy now will literally
dedicate six months if not a year to one race.
And he will be thinking about that race the
whole time.
He'll be developing his bike with a view to
that race.
He'll be getting coaching with a view to that
race.
And that really wasn't the case.
And that kind of falsifies Merckx's achievements
when you compare them to achievements nowadays.
Is he probably wasn't as good pound for pound
in the Tour de France as you know whoever
wins it this year would be.
He would lose.
Because he was never as fit I don't think
as the guys are now.
But he, he was good enough throughout the
years to beat those guys cause they didn't
have access to those things.
>>Ned: So the modern sport would force him
if you like to specialize, to choose one of
those routes.
And what would be that route do you think?
What was his single greatest strength?
Was it – –
>>Daniel: I mean I think.
>>Ned: Would he be [Migar Linderhine]?
>>Daniel: I think he would be a one-day racer.
I mean he's a fairly big guy, six-foot and
weighs 75 kg.
I would imagine that he would concentrate
on the classics, the one-day races in springtime.
>>Richard: He'd be a far more limited rider
then wouldn't he?
And he probably wouldn't have the respect
that is his due?
I mean he's not.
Because you couldn't imagine him really going
head-to-head with some of the great climbers.
Why were those great climbers not able to
put him on the ropes back in the day?
>>Daniel: It's not were.
But again I think there's another aspect of
it was this aura.
And he, particularly the first year when he
won the Tour de France in 1969, he really
traumatized people.
There was actually a quote from a guy, one
of his old team managers in my book saying,
he actually, you know, they were shell-shocked.
Not just for a few weeks, but for years afterwards.
And one of the things he said to me was, "They
would never, they would not dare to attack
because it was like literally dangling bait
in front of him."
And as soon as you attack, that was literally
like lighting.
>>Richard: Tell us the great story about the
wine.
Zandegù and the wine.
>>Ned: Yeah.
>>Daniel: I remember the tour with him, [inaudible]
>>Daniel: No I mean you know races, the Tour
de France, now you get the hotspot sprints
for points for the green jersey.
Whereas it used to be very common for the
spot prices to be up for grabs, like bottles
of wine.
On this particular case in the Tour of Italy,
they went past this famous Italian singer's
Château kind of castle manor house that he
had.
And he was putting up 50 bottles of Chianti
for the winner of this sprint.
And this Italian rider Dino Zandegù who became
a bit of a folk hero because he was just,
he was a circus act.
You know he would, appear holding birthday
cakes in the middle of the race and singing
"Happy birthday."
[laughter]
So this one day he resolved that he was gonna
win this Chianti.
He said whenever there was wine up for grab,
and this is something that I kind of picked
up when I interviewed him.
Because you could kind of tell he was fond
of a glass of Chianti or two
>>Richard: He got drunk during the course
of the day, didn't he?
>>Daniel: But he was particularly motivated
for this kind of sprint.
So on this one day, he described it in perfect
detail.
You know coming around a bridge and there
it was the banner.
And he could see it, and off he went.
And he was a sprinter anyway, so on this particular
he managed to beat Merckx.
Completely meaningless, Merckx was gonna win
the race.
He was minutes ahead on the general classification.
And when he saw Zandegù cross the line, he
was screaming at you, "You bastardo, you'll
never race again."
Or "I'm gonna kill you", and, "That Chianti's
mine."
Anyway that night, they were all staying in
the same hotel, all the teams up on Copper
Mountain.
And Merckx knocked on his door and demanding
half of the Chianti otherwise he was gonna
see to it that this guy never race again.
That's kind of, I'm sure there's a degree
of truth in that.
But I'm not sure –
>>Richard: The other day he beat Merckx again
and had to hide in somebody's house.
>>Daniel: Beat Merckx again and he pulled
off the road just after the finish line, and
he burst into this little wooden shack near
the finish line to a completely deserted house
and he went upstairs.
And there was an eighty-year-old woman asleep,
and she started screaming.
He said "Granny, granny don't worry, I'm not
gonna do anything to you, but Eddy Merckx
is chasing me and he wants to rip my head
and face off."
[laughter]
He actually saved it now, I mean I didn't
believe a word of it.
[laughter]
But hope I present it in the book in such
a way that.
>>Richard: You get a sense that Zandegù is
a circus act.
It's interesting because paradoxically Merckx,
you know the way you describe him there he's
sort of a mafia boss or a bully.
And yet he's quite gentle guy as well.
He's got this, and he's racked by the insecurity
and doubt himself.
You know, which in contrast to this marauding
bullying bike rider and racer that he was.
>>Ned: That's no different from lots of bike
riders is it?
>>Daniel: Same with Cavendish.
>>Ned: There's a life on the bike and there's
a life off the bike.
>>Richard: Apart from Lance Armstrong who
kind of had that.
>>Ned: took his on bike persona and turned
it into his off bike.
>>Richard: And you know Armstrong was probably
well you know and then Armstrong was the next
guy.
[Inaudible]
>>Richard: That was completely accidental,
that was totally accidental.
>>Ned: Should we ask him about that?
>>Daniel: Let's ask him about that.
>>Richard: Oh goodness, if you must.
[laughter]
>>Daniel: So you've written a book called
"Slaying the Badger."
Now "the badger" is Bernard Hinault.
Which you want to explain first of all how
he got this nickname and why it's appropriate?
>>Richard: I don't think the reason why he
got the nickname owes to the person he became
in a way.
It's kind of odd, the origins of it were apparently
when he was a young cyclist, a teammate from
Brittany used to greet him "Hey badger, hey
blairo."
>>Daniel: It's quite common in France isn't
it?
>>Richard: Apparently in Brittany it's a common
form of greeting, "Hey badger.
" [chuckles] So with Hinault this kind of
stuck.
And then I think I had this image of a badger
as this cuddly kind of toy.
And a badger is really pretty vicious apparently.
And the jaw kind of, once it clamps, you can
only get it off by dislocating the jaw apparently.
And that sums up Hinault to a T. He grew into
that nickname, and it caught on.
And you know, when, when I went with a good
friend/translator of mine and Daniel to interview
him.
You know we asked him, he quite liked it,
didn't he?
And he goes, "Yeah."
And I think it kind of suited him.
He said, "Badgers a little bit nasty like
me."
So it does kind of sum him up, yeah.
>>Ned: In terms of what happened on a bike,
sorry Daniel.
When I read your book a while ago, when I
had been reading Daniels.
The way in the general classification Merckx
would make decisive moves that would nowadays
in the modern era be considered suicidal.
Cause they just go off with 100 km to go on
their own and just kind of wing it.
"Let's get this done, let's just do it."
Hinault was the same right?
I mean repeatedly that would be his modus
operandi.
>>Richard: To a point, in the early part of
his career certainly.
And it's interesting cause Hinault retired,
I'm sorry, Merckx retired in 78', the year
that Hinault won his first Tour de France.
And I think Anquetil retired the year that
Merckx also won his first tour.
Or there was some neat cut off between these
eras.
And there was the Anquetil era, followed by
the Merckx era followed almost directly afterward
by the Hinault era.
And Hinault was, he was so physically capable
I think that early on in his career, you know
he realized he could win big races and he
was quite aggressive.
He suffered a bad knee injury in 1980.
And it caused him to withdraw from the tour
midway through when he was wearing the yellow
jersey.
And in the dead of night, after the Germans
had done their stories for the next day Hinault
orchestrated this exit which didn't go down
very well for journalists.
And after that, he was a slightly different
kind of rider.
He did go to the world championship that year
and won it in that style, that buccaneering.
But he was more calculating afterwards.
And that calculation extended to individual
races but also to his career.
He became far more selective.
Not quite as selective as Lance Armstrong
who only went to the tour to win each year.
But far more selective than Merckx had been.
You know he set his sights on, he had appointments.
And when he turned up for an appointment he
won it every time.
He would say, "I'm gonna win that race", and
he would go and win it.
And at other races he would sort of become
this incredible teammate to his, to lesser
riders who he would help and act as this incredible
domestique.
And speaking to his former teammates, they
were, they spoke so kind of warmly even lovingly
of him.
Which again is in stark contrast to the image
that we had of him and the image that his
rivals had of him.
Because he was a brute and a bully.
>>Daniel: Particularly in this Tour de France
that your book is about.
>>Richard: Yeah the books about the 86' tour
where he and the American Greg LeMond lined
up in the same La Vie Claire team.
The previous year in 85', Hinault had won
his fifth tour.
But he'd done so with the help of LeMond.
I mean he probably wouldn't have won that
tour had LeMond not helped them.
He had a terrible crash Saint-Étienne and
sort of finished the race with a broken nose
and bronchitis, two black eyes.
It looked brilliant.
[laughter]
But he struggled to the line and LeMond had
helped him.
And LeMond probably had his chance to win
that tourney, he held back on team orders
in order to help Hinault.
And Hinault allegedly promised him that he
would help him the following year which was
Hinault's final tour in '86.
And he made this pledge to help LeMond to
win it.
And he made it to several people LeMond himself
and to journalist.
But of course as the '86 tour approaches,
people are starting to question whether Hinault
will honor the pledge.
And he has, you know the President of France
urging him to forget about it.
The whole French media and people really you
know forget about the American.
You know go for the sixth tour which would've
been historic.
You know in front of Merckx and Anquetil as
a six-time winner.
So the temptation was huge.
And really as the tour began it seemed to
be very much open.
And as it began, and as it went into its first
week and then hit the tourneys, it became
very very obvious to everybody, especially
LeMond that Hinault was not going to help
LeMond, he was out to try to win it himself.
So what followed was this fascinating kind
of internal battle between them and their
own team.
And the team you know ended up being split
and down the middle really, with the Swiss
riders in the middle as neutrals.
And it was fascinating.
>>Daniel: Two very contrasting characters,
but you had two very contrasting experiences
of Etienne, talk a little bit about them
>>Richard: Yeah, I mean Hinault.
LeMond is very open and friendly and warm.
Whereas Hinault is very cold and coarse and
short.
And I went into LeMond, you know the book
is, it's funny because the book is about LeMond
and Hinault.
But Hinault is the person that really seems
to fascinate people.
But LeMond is equally fascinating in his own
way.
He was this kinda young prodigy who wasn't
streetwise in the way that Hinault was, he
was just hugely, hugely talented.
But he was wracked by insecurity, by doubt,
by fragility.
And it was not just a physical.
>>Ned: Wracked by diarrhea at one point.
>>Richard: Wracked by diarrhea.
It was not just physical battle between them,
it was the psychological battle.
Are you trying to get me to read it?
>>Ned: No, no.
>>Richard: And LeMond you know went into LeMond
and he was just.
He'd been very hard to pin down initially.
You know 9 months it took me to arrange an
interview with him.
And to go and see him.
And once I was face-to-face with him, he couldn't
have been better.
I mean he was brilliant.
And just the stories that will come out of
him were just incredible.
Such a contrast to Hinault.
He's become more, because Hinault you know
did subject him to a very horrendous experience
during that tour.
You know I think it was pretty, it was pretty
hard and pretty harrowing.
But he's kind of softened to Hinault over
the years.
He's kind forgiven him in a way.
Because I think he understands now why Hinault
did it.
Why it was important to him.
I don't think, I think for Hinault to have
been seen to be just basically riding in the
service of LeMond I think it would've damaged
Hinault 's legacy.
And I think Hinault kind of on some level
realized that.
And so the only way for him to help LeMond
or to be beaten was to kind of go down all
guns blazing in the way that he did.
I think if Hinault can rationalize that, I
think that's probably what he did.
>>Ned: And still the last French winner of
the tour which is--
>>Richard: 85'
>>Ned: --just extraordinary isn't it?
Is that a way of bringing things up to date
and maybe just sort of throwing it open to.
I mean, there may be no questions in which
case were happy to ramble on.
We can ramble on all day.
>>Richard: And I can give the diarrhea story.
>>Ned: Yeah, go for it, yeah.
[laughter]
>>male 1: A question for Daniel about the
ghost writing process.
You said it was very different from Merckx
and LeMond.
Could you describe how [inaudible]
>>Daniel: Oh Merckx is not a ghost, it's not
an autobiography.
It's a biography.
No,
>>Ned: He said no.
[laughter]
>>Daniel: No not at all.
m>>Male 1: [Inaudible]?
>>Daniel: How'd it work?
So, I mean, I think people do it.
Rich has done a couple of ghost writing jobs.
>>Richard: One, yeah.
>>male 1: Oh OK.
>>Daniel: But we, I think they work broadly
the same way.
So I spent about a week with Mark.
Yeah, it's too long to do like the whole day.
So you do maybe two hours in the morning,
two hours at night.
You know that gives you a number of hours,
and then you.
We probably did 20, 25 hours in total.
He was really fine.
The most alarm, well there were a lot of alarming
moments in the process I would say.
The one that sticks in my mind will always
be and you probably heard this story, I've
told this story to so many people.
But when I finished the manuscript, and his
girlfriend, and how that overlaps with the
book you know that's another good story.
[laughter]
>>male 2: Can we get that story?
>>Daniel: Yeah, we can get that story.
>>male 1: [Inaudible]
>>Daniel: Might be it might be, bear with
me.
Yeah so I finished the manuscript and I went
to see Mark.
And Melissa his girlfriend at the time was
you know I knew her because I'd been in that
house a lot.
And she was, and she would generally be my
point of contact when I couldn't.
He was sometimes a nightmare.
I remember one day saying , I was at the end
of my tether.
I couldn't get a hold of him and she sent
me, I sent her a message "Can you please get
him to call me?"
She sent me one back, "That lying little git.
I've had just about enough of this."
But anyway, we finished the manuscript and
I went to meet them in Manchester.
And, just to get a bit of feedback from them
about what they thought about it.
And you know, we ordered drinks in this bar
and we're sitting there.
And Melissa's there and Mark's there and I
said "So guys how was it?
What you think of it?"
And Mark is saying oh yeah yeah yeah great
manual, great work.
And I turned to Melissa and said "What about
you Melissa?"
And she said "Well you know, there are a few
things that happen that you describe them,
it wasn't exactly the way they happen.
Like the Way, Mark proposed to me."
And these days I could see the fury that Ned's
probably familiar with Mark eyes.
And he turned to her, and there was a pause
of about 10 seconds.
Then he went, "Melissa, it's a fucking story."
[laughter]
And I said, "Hang on Mark, it's not fictional."
And yeah generally it was fine.
[laughter]
The thing about the girlfriend, I'm not sure
I want to go into it really.
I mean he happened to dedicate it to Melissa.
>>male 3: [Inaudible]
>>Daniel: You're right, actually I do remember
now.
Yeah.
I mean, he happened to split up with Melissa
just as the hot bite came out, which was unfortunate.
>>male 4: Do you think he's gonna be able
to cope at Skye without having the team, the
full support of the team?
>>male 5: [Inaudible]
>>Ned: Well I think it is something.
We talked about this haven't we briefly, but
I think it's, there's only one answer that,
it's thoroughly compromised isn't it?
But whichever way you look at it, is compromised.
If they pulled it off it would be astonishing.
I don't, I don't know if they will pull it
off.
>>male 4: [Inaudible]
>>Ned: Yeah it's a different era, they were
all doping for a start.
[laughter]
You know.
And then, for all that they did pull it off,
they also didn't put it off as well.
It wasn't like the recipe that worked every
single time.
Let's not forget how Jan Ullrich kind of used
to try throw down his opposition to Lance
Armstrong in this kind a team full of chiefs.
There were 30 Indians and no chief.
It's frustrating to me because the more and
more I think about this year's Tour de France
and the way that the tour has been designed
with two longtime trials.
And the absence of Alberto Contador.
The more I think that this is Bradley Wiggins'
only and best chance of winning the Tour de
France.
And if Dave Brailsford when he calls Team
Sky into existence, if his stated aim of producing
a British Tour de France winner within five
years had any credibility than this is the
moment.
And I think that they should really be throwing
the kitchen sink at Bradley Wiggins and his
tour.
Where the desire and the impulse and the motor
actually came from to sign Mark Cavendish
on this multimillion pound contract.
Which in one sense seems entirely obvious.
But where that came from I don't know, how
high up within the organization of Skye you
have to go.
Whether it actually came from Dave Brailsford
himself or someone above him I don't know.
>>Richard: The irony I think is that it was
almost the end of the, the move was engineered,
or came when there were serious doubts about
whether aim of winning the tour was actually
achievable.
>>Ned: Absolutely, so like a very solid Plan
B.
>>Richard: The move was basically done in
the first part of last year on the back of
Wiggins having quite a spectacular failure
at the 2010 tour.
When it really didn't look at that point like
he was ever gonna actually become a tour winner.
And if somebody did emerge as a potential
tour winner, it would be a bit further down
the line.
You know Cavendish is your banker for lots
of wins, lots of publicity.
And then, the same Cavendish and Wiggins than
you know finishes third in the Vuelta with
Chris Froome second.
And suddenly, you know.
But I can see, I can understand why they retained
Cavendish.
The most bankable name and world cycling really.
And there's still an element, momentum seems
to be building towards Wiggins certainly starting
to tour as a favorite.
And you know some people are already talking
about it being his to lose which.
>>Daniel: I'm not sure about that.
>>Ned: You're not overstating it.
>>Richard: I think so.
>>Ned: Cadel Evans is still probably the favorite
given his experience.
>>Richard: I think you know you can, with
someone who's, with Lance Armstrong, there
was an element of certainty.
Because, you know.
But with Wiggins he's finishing third in the
Vuelta last year I don't think it's enough
solid proof that he can win the tour.
Winning Pyrenees is not enough solid evidence
that he can win the tour.
But I think he's definitely capable of doing
it.
And I think you're right, that it has to be
a concerted effort.
I think that the way it's coming out they
might you know, Cavendish might be winging
it a little bit and not have the lead out
train and be left to his own devices.
I don't know if you.
>>Daniel: I think the big problem could be
groups within the group.
I think basically the problem is, and what
the guys at T-Mobile use say is they had to
do two jobs.
And what ended up deciding who they worked
for that day or in that particular moment
when they felt you know pulled in two directions
was often who they like more.
And that is another issue.
I think Mark's probably more of a natural
leader then Bradley.
At Mark also pisses people off, can piss people
off, although he is a great leader.
So that's another thing they've got a guard
against whether you know just in terms of
morale in the team.
If all these guys who are doing the kind of
worker bees, if they get really tired and
they get down in people's moods are kind of
fickle in the Tour de France because they're
so tired.
Then I think it'll be difficult to manage
maybe.
>>Ned: And the other factor, I'll come to
you in a second.
Just to throw in, you may be preempting your
question here.
But you mentioned his name briefly is Chris
Froome.
He might end up being the story of the summer.
We're focusing on Wiggins and Cavendish, but
he's a big unknown.
You know his bilharzia, his recurrent bilharzia.
And then he came down with pneumonia.
And then he got rid of that and he went off
to Kenya to his brother's wedding came back
with typhoid.
So he's been wiped out for months, but he's
in full training now and he's off on the tour
of Romandie.
So he could be capable of anything or nothing.
But if he's capable of anything, that anything
just might be winning the Tour de France.
>>Richard: If it's like the Vuelta last year
where he was stronger.
>>Ned: He was the stronger of the two.
Let's sorry, a question in the blue shirt.
>>male 6: [Inaudible]
Recently it hasn't really got my interest.
I think it's because I thought everybody was
using drugs or doping.
So my question to you is [Inaudible] because
right now I feel after 6 months [Inaudible]
>>Ned: That's a big one.
>>Daniel: I mean, there's no doubt that drugs
have been in cycling from the start pretty
much.
I mean strychnine, caffeine from the start.
>>Richard: Morphine, alcohol.
>>Ned: There's various different kinds.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
And I mean one misconception, one of the things
I talk about in my book is that it used to
be.
Now they refer to it as light doping i.e.
like stimulants and caffeine whereas now it's
heavy doping.
Because I think people of made a leap in their
minds because now it's syringes, and it kind
of seems slightly sordid.
Blood bags you know and shadowy doctors.
Whereas back then, it was, it seemed quite
innocent in a way.
But it's always been there.
And that is a misconception, you know a lot
of the methods and products that were around
now were around 30, 40 years ago.
It's just that, we've stigmatized in a way
by making the punishments more draconian.
You know we say now its two years, four years
and all of the sudden in people's minds "God
this is a really terrible crime."
Whereas if you say you're banned for a week,
then people start to view it as something
that's kind of trifling.
>>Ned: Eddy Mokes got a month right?
>>Daniel: And then it was, yeah he didn't
even get the month.
So that's one of the things.
>>Ned: Yeah, I would suggest that, even in
the 10 years I've been covering it actually.
And I understand entirely what you're saying,
you're right to feel that in some ways.
But I would suggest hesitantly that actually
incrementally over those 10 years the instances
of doping have come down, year on year.
And even those instances where people have
doped, I think probably the percentage of
advantage they're gaining is probably smaller.
In other words, the conclusion I'm trying
to draw is that it's getting better.
And so what you do?
Is this a point to give up on it?
I'm not sure it is.
I think that probably they, it's heading in
the right direction albeit slowly.
>>Richard: I'm recently comforted in that
clean the riders are winning big races now
in a way that it wasn't 10 years ago.
>>Daniel: Yeah.
>>Richard: When I say clean, it's all relative.
I mean we have this.
Well I'm not casting aspersions here at all.
You know we have this very black and white
viewpoint of doping that you're either a drug
cheat or you're not.
And it's just so complex you know there's
this huge gray area, and the actual line between
doping and clean is moving all the time.
You know that's something I covered in another
book about Team Sky where you know it was
very obvious that if you’re a professional
athlete, if you're training for the Tour de
France it's your job to go it's close to that
line is possible.
And to do everything that you can that is
legal.
Which might not be considered natural or even
ethical, I don't know.
And by some people.
Athletes at that level are doing things and
taking things that the rest of us would regard
as crazy.
But it's kind of the responsibility to do
that.
They would be kind of silly not to I think.
In a way.
So I think it's a very foggy area.
And there isn't this kind of, an athlete doesn't
decide alright I'm gonna dope today, I'm gonna
go from being a clean rider to a cheat.
I think as David Miller very eloquently described
in his book, it's a process.
But, there's always this puzzle.
This game of being as close to that line as
you can possibly be.
>>Daniel: The other thing I'd say is that
there's this misconception that the media
knows.
It's a charge that's often leveled at us that
we spent time with these athletes.
We do have really good access like Ned said
earlier.
We don't know, we have no idea.
And the athletes themselves have no idea what
another guy.
I mean in some cases they might.
You know, at the Tour de France, the pressroom
is, you will not ever walked into a more cynicism
fueled room.
You know we watch the stage on the big screen
and you know as soon as anyone does something
incredible they'll be a nudge, nudge and a
wink, wink.
But really we don't know.
>>Ned: Rumors.
>>Daniel: And often we're basing that on stereotypes.
>>Ned: And sometimes you'll be live to a,
I mean I don't dwell on it.
You will be live to a decent rumor that you
can follow through and actually affect the
challenge.
I mean that does happen.
It happened with me and Stephan Schumacher
after his time trial win where I basically
accused him of doping.
He was wearing the yellow jersey at the tour,
he didn't like it one bit.
But I was right and he was wrong you know.
And he's, it doesn't always happen, you gotta
be pretty sure of your ground.
It happened with Rasmussen, albeit he never
failed a dope test.
Sorry can I just come to this guy?
>>male 7: do you think the relevance [Inaudible]
over the past few years [inaudible]
>>Ned: Yeah.
Doesn't look good.
>>male 7: Do you think that's something that
we seize upon?
Is it fair to seize upon that [Inaudible].
Is it something that it's just you do something
that doesn't say you're one or the other?
>>Richard: I think it's dangerous to make
any assumptions isn't it?
I mean we could make the same assumption about
Chris Froome who rode into second in the Vuelta
last year.
But we knew that he'd been ill and that you
had this terrible bad luck.
So, it's like a very British mindset perhaps.
You know the cheating foreigners and the plucky
Brit.
So you know, I think it's always dangerous
to make assumptions one way or the other.
There could be a logical explanation.
I mean Joe Barr apparently had dental problems
that could explain it, who knows.
Inconsistency though, or massive leap in improvements.
>>Ned: Thomas Voeckler
>>Richard: It's always suspicious.
>>Ned: Yeah.
>>Daniel: Tom Boland.
>>Richard: Well there's an interesting little
bit in your book your new book the e-book,
where you have a conversation with an ESO
official who suggests that.
>>Ned: I mean on last year's tour there at
this funny moment where it almost became a
possibility that Thomas Voeckler would win
the Tour de France.
I mean having been not up to consideration,
it just flickered for second, hang on this
ain't gonna happen is it?
But after 10 days in the yellow at which point
I said this guy who is very high up in the
organization, I said.
>>Richard: What's his name?
>>Ned: Matthieu Peres.
And I said, "That would be a thing wouldn't
it?
Out of nowhere of Frenchman after all this
time winning you know we're two days from
Paris.
This could happen."
And he went, "I hope it doesn't happen.
This needs to stop now."
And I went, "No!?", and he goes.
[laughter]
Now I don't know, he's not party to information.
But he sensitive to those insinuations.
And to the image of the tour.
>>Richard: Yeah.
>>Daniel: This is on YouTube Ned, you know
that right.
>>Ned: Yeah.
[laughter]
>>Richard: Bleep that bit out.
>>male 8: [Inaudible]
>>Richard: More time to think, I think.
>>Daniel: I think that cycling in sports that's
least vulnerable to that kind of thing.
Because I think the sport where you feel that
most is probably something like golf where
you're stationary.
Because no seriously.
[laughter]
No because it's also it's a physiological
thing, it's a hormonal thing.
If you're moving, if you're moving fast your
producing hormones which will ultimately often
they will kind of muffle the stress.
You know like that adrenaline that works against
stress a lot of the time without becoming
more nervous.
I think generally – –
>>Richard: It's a sport Daniel.
>>Daniel: I, but yeah outside of when they're
actually performing.
Yeah I think all sportsmen are susceptible.
>>Richard: I think the self-doubt thing, it
can be the difference between you know you
start with Ullrich and Armstrong's, or any,
LeMond Hinault.
Any rivalry where that's really exposed.
Often the difference is confidence, self-confidence.
>>Ned: And actually there's a really good
case in point just the other week wasn't there
with Johnny Hoogerland.
I don't know how closely you been following
this season.
But he's a kind of marauding, he doesn't quite
know what he is kind of rider, but he's got
bundles of aggression and a lot of talent.
And in Milan-San Ramo he kept attacking and
in slightly inappropriate places and having
a go.
And actually, his DS came out and said he's
doing that because his self-confidence is
brittle.
Cause he doesn't know how to get the best
out of himself.
>>Richard: It's ironic isn't it.
We can see, I think the with Pantani as well.
Some of these great you know really excited
climbers are often the ones who are most wracked
by self-doubt.
And they're not happy unless they are you
know.
If they're sitting in the bunch waiting for
things to happen they are not happy.
And it takes a very confident rider to actually
just sit there and control it.
And someone like Armstrong who would say this
was the key moment of the race, this is where
I'm gonna set it alight.
And do that.
>>Daniel: But it's interesting that some people
can turn that into fuel and other people,
for other people it would just kill their
performances.
I mean that was, for Merckx, he was just as
wracked with self-doubt as any rider you will
ever find.
>>Richard: The nature of cycling, particularly
with the hours of training and racing, it
does, if you're an introspective sort it's
gonna make you worse.
I think climbing is the same.
I think that's why there's some really good,
not these ones obviously, but there are some
really good books out about cycling.
Because there is that time to think and like
there's great climbing literature as well.
Because people have this time to think and
to you know David Miller book for example
is a product of you know years of introspection.
And he's intelligent enough to turn that introspection
into this coherent story.
And that I think is a fact of the sport definitely
significant.
>.Ned: And the psychological fuel thing, you
said using it as a fuel.
Just to quote Gary Imlach who presents our
coverage, who's I think a brilliant brilliant
journalist.
He once summed up Lance Armstrong at the end
of one of our shows after he had that spat
with Simeoni in the best way possible.
He said, "Lance Armstrong needs grudges like
the flying Scotsman needs a steady supply
of coal."
[laughter]
Which I thought was just brilliant.
>>male 9: Speaking of psychology, can you
talk a little bit about [inaudible]
[laughter]
[Inaudible]
>>Ned: Andy really disappointed me.
I mean, last, I mean he disappointed me in
so many ways you know over the last couple
years.
I think if they're head-to-head against Contador
on the Tour Mila in the pissing rain it just
didn't happen.
Maybe there were sporting reasons for that,
I don't know.
But where were the fireworks, where was the
attempt?
The most disappointing memory, or recent memory
of Andy Shleck is interviewing him on the
Champs-Elysees last year at the tour where
he finished in second.
And I said, "Andy, sum it all up.
Now you're here, you've reached Paris.
When you look back in 10 years, what will
you think about this tour."
And he said, "I'm immensely proud to finish
second in the Tour de France."
[laughter]
He should've won it, last year he should've
won it.
Shouldn't he have?
And even if he's just trying to say the right
thing, and I actually believe he's kind of,
he's got himself into that mindset where he
actually is immensely proud of finishing second,
which is, I've never finished second you never
finished second you know It's a rare place
to be.
But with his talent.
He should be, I mean would Mark Cavendish
say, "I'm immensely proud to finish second
in the sprint"?
You know, that's what kind maddens me about
Andy Shleck a little.
>>Daniel: I was reading the interview with
Andy Murray in Sport magazine earlier and
he said, "In what other domain would you be
the fourth best in the world at something
and still be criticized."
And I was writing about Andy Shleck yesterday,
and it occurred to me we were very harsh about
him.
But actually he's the second-best, you know
last year he was the second best rider in
the biggest race in the world.
It's not bad.
The other thing about the Shleck's is, I think
if you go to Luxembourg you start to understand
what a goldfish bowl it is for them.
I mean Luxembourg is not exactly, the cup
does not runneth over with celebrities.
And you know in any business.
>>Ned: Nor does Frank.
>>Daniel: Exactly.
And they live in the same house.
And then there was their Dad John before that.
>>Ned: Yeah exactly.
>>Daniel: I remember that worked both ways.
On the one hand you know they're mates for
life, they don't, they're the biggest stars
in the country.
Also there's a lot of pressure.
There's a huge amount of pressure on them,
especially with the team now having a kind
of Luxembourg identity.
>>male 9: Do you think they would be better
if they were on separate teams?
>>Richard: It's funny I mean yeah you could
see them riding certainly last year.
I remember Plateau de Bais stage where you
felt that one would accelerate and then look
to see where the other one was.
And they have that brotherly bond which is
both a help than a hindrance really.
You know, had Cadel Evans not been riding
last year, and had he not been riding as well
as he was then they would have probably finished
first and second in the Tour and we've been
seeing this remarkable, these wonderful brothers.
So you know it's close to being an incredible
story and I think it is a story of unfulfilled
promise really.
At the moment, you know.
When Andy Schleck emerged and finished second
in the Giro as a 21-year-old or something
in 2007.
And we thought my God this guy is a bit like
Jan Ullrich when he won the tour and '97.
It was, we thought this guy is the new Merckx
or Hinault or somebody, he's just so so talented.
And you wouldn't have thought then that he
would get to this age and not have won a grand
tour.
>>Ned: He's got Contador in his way more often
than not.
And Contador's an amazing story in his own
right.
Because he's been, I think I'm right in saying
he's been not eligible to ride four Tour's
de France is.
I think that's right.
You know one way or the other with Astana
and bans.
I mean it's just extraordinary.
And he should be, we should be talking about
Contador had things panned out differently
in the same tones that we talk about Merckx
and Armstrong and Hinault, greatest stage
racer of his generation.
But that ain't gonna happen now.
>>male 10: [Inaudible]
>>Richard: Until your ban is almost over.
>>Ned: Ninety-nine days til his ban is up.
Just in time for the Tour of Britain.
[laughter]
You gonna see them lining up in Gilford.
Sorry, I mean I'm, what do you mean?
>>,ale 10: Inaudible
>>Ned: Plenty doesn't look good about his
cleanliness.
And the bottom line is that none of us know
do we but the inalienable fact in all that
is that he had Clenbuterol in his system.
That's only fact you can return to.
>>male 11: One of my favorite things [inaudible]
>>Ned: Well, I know very little about bikes,
and these guys know an awful lot more.
Well I guess they do, you've ridden a bike
so you must know.
At first I thought it was absolutely hilarious,
and I couldn't believe that it was.
But by all accounts it's, it is a kind of
real possibility isn't it technically that
you could.
>>Richard: I wouldn't dismiss it as a real
possibility.
Somebody recently said something to me that
suggested it may be a real possibility.
>>Daniel: I remember conversations that we
had in the car at the Tour de France about
what would be the next step, would it be geographical
doping?
As in—
>>Richard: retro doping.
>>Daniel: Yeah, retro doping.
You know the first Tour de France people used
to catch the train then they used to pack
packs on the road.
[laughter]
[Inaudible]
>>Richard: Yeah, that'd would be fun to return
to those days wouldn't it?
>>Daniel: But the guy who made the first YouTube
video and compiled all the evidence, yes he
went on to write a book about that.
In Italy yeah it's come out.
A thick tome all about mechanical doping.
But it was quite convincing when you watch
that piece.
Well, sorry?
>>male 11: [Inaudible]
>>Daniel: I mean it kind of did look like
that.
>>Richard: There was this book that came out
that [inaudible]
[laughter]
>>Richard: Really suspicious.
>>Richard: Yeah, but you know I mean he did
something that wasn't any more extraordinary
than Tom Boonen did this year.
I mean Cancellara went away with I think with
40 K's to go, just under 40 K's to go and
Boonen went away with just over 50.
And what if he had a motor?
But I didn't hear the mechanical doping rumors
then.
>>Ned: That's good punish.
>>Richard: On the same bike as well wasn't
it?
A specialized bike.
>>Daniel: It's quite funny, the Belgian said
there's a whole kind of microculture of Belgians
in like the press room and cycling in general.
And they have their own language, it's not
a language because they don't speak.
It's just kind of winks and nudges.
There, and the standard, their standard sign
language for someone basically doing what
Cancellara or Boonen did is like "grrrrr"
like that.
They actually did it to the riders in the
morning, they walk around the buses "grrrr".
[laughter]
>>Christina: I hate to cut this short but
we can only have just one more question.
I think we might be getting to the end.
>>male 12: Yeah so how is Team Sky running
all over the UK, and what else do you think
they can do to promote the sport?
>>Daniel: I was asked the same question the
other day in a similar event.
And I, this was the last question I ended
it on the grimmest and most depressing note
possible.
So I'll get it out of the way and then you
guys can.
>>Ned: I agree with you though.
>>Daniel: So in racing a similar thing happened.
The boom in cycling in this country.
We talked about it a lot.
Rich and I have actually discussed whether
it is actually happened or something that
we like to imagine is happening in our head.
And comfort is when we feel bad about our
freelance careers.
But it is, I think it is happening.
But it also happened in Germany a few years
ago.
And that went from nothing to you know stratosphere
within two or three years.
When Jan Ullrich won the Tour de France.
I was writing I think about another rider
Andreas Kloden a few days ago.
And in the introduction it was all about how
cycling in Germany was just taking off.
There was Kloden, there were guys under him.
Patrik Sinkewitz who a couple years later
was banned.
But it literally went from one day to the
next it went from everything to nothing.
I don't think that will happen in this country.
>>Richard: But what was the statistic on,
cause it was a very similar story in a sense.
They had a big German team that was supposed
to have a bid German brand.
But you were telling me about just the kind
of money that they had.
>>Daniel: Yeah I mean well they would fly
130 journalists just to their training camp.
German journalists at the start of the year.
And the riders said they were just groveling
these guys to get the riders in their paper.
Now you will not find any media coverage about
cycling in Germany.
And there was a huge sponsor, it was like
Sky it was T-Mobile.
So that is a cautionary tale.
I don't think it'll happen.
But it might.
>>Ned: There are very specific reasons for
that collapse though aren't there, almost
all doping related, so a little hedge on that.
But I take your point, it's a brittle foundation,
and it seems a bit grafted on.
A kind of carbon fiber shell that we've built
over, a pretty rusty edifice.
You've got to let, you got a hope that enough
time elapses for these roots to really take
hold.
The other thing that fueled the German collapse
was the moral high grounds that the broadcasters
took national television in Germany, ZDF and
AL TV said well, not showing the race, sod
ya.
But ITV don't have a moral high ground, or
show it whatever.
[laughter]
>>Richard: Yeah I guess in the Britain in
a sense it began almost even before, cause
Armstrong was kind of important I think here
as well.
You know certainly in the books boom Armstrong's
books did so well that it transcended the
sport.
And it convinced publishers the cycling book,
there was an audience for cycling books.
So there's always been that kind of hard-core
following in the UK.
It certainly, it's kind of growing all the
time, you really feel it multiplying.
I mean Ned made a comment the other day saying
that you know it was a bit like Andy Murray
in tennis that we only really have one guy
or two guys at the top.
I don't agree with that.
I think there are slightly stronger foundations.
There are guys coming through British riders
on top teams now worldwide, where there wasn't
10, 15, 20 years ago.
Dave Miller was the only one 10 years ago.
So there's that encouragement.
The other thing that's helped enormously has
been lottery funding with the track program.
My worry is that after London that's reduced
and that starts to diminish a little bit.
And Dave Brills may leave the British program.
And that might, and that is a very important
foundation that might begin to crumble.
>>male 13: [Inaudible]
>>Richard: Not on its own, I mean it needs,
you know I think there are the pro scene and
in the UK at the moment is pretty healthy.
Again you know were in a recession again apparently
and these things are very much dependent on
corporate sponsorship, and if that disappears.
>>Ned: And there's one big sponsor, and they're
all gravitating towards that sponsor.
You know John Tannock is an example of a British
rider from outside the system where you know
he's gonna be riding for them next year.
So don't put all your eggs in one basket,
it's a bit risky.
>>Richard: I mean having said that, you know
there certainly is a huge huge interest in
it.
And you know that, I think that is real.
But I think that I mean you totally see people
cycling and you see I think that there's,
the evidence is before us.
>>Daniel: We desperately desperately need
it to carry on.
>>Richard: Were screwed if it doesn't carry
on.
[laughter]
>>Ned: Thank you very much, cheers.
[applause]